does it ever get emotional for you and
people ruin young kids you know being a
role model and a great example and
especially some of that young black
girls or girls of any ethnicity can look
up to does it ever get emotional when
they reach out to you and tell you
you're inspiring or the wish they could
be like you or you got me through
something oh yeah it does it really does
it moves me a lot the other day I was at
the SAG Awards and afterwards a man came
over with his daughter his adopted
daughter she wanted to picture with me
and she just broke down and cried and I
just held her and I was like what is
wrong and she just said it's just so
nice to meet you and I could see that
that wasn't all there was more to this
to her and I didn't need to hear what I
meant to her but I could feel it and it
moved me and I was just like I was so I
was just I felt like crying I can't do
that I was supposed to be the strong one
in the situation but you know it stayed
with me it really does stay with me when
I hear about that and I'm honored to
have that position the Petersons
breaking down barriers ever since she
became the first Kenyan and Mexican
actress to win an Academy Award for her
performance in 12 years a slave now she
wants to continue pushing boundaries in
her upcoming role in black panther not
only is this a movie that young kids I
never had growing up but as well like
black females are very rarely given the
chance where they're able to be so
powerful yeah I mean this movie is a
game-changer I mean I hadn't seen a
movie like this that's why I wanted to
be in a movie like this the fact that
this is a fictitious African nation that
is so inspired by the real African
continent you know that all the cultures
all the culture of Wakanda is inspired
and derived from real cultures on the
continent
the aesthetic all of it is informed by
real people the hairstyles the look the
feel and then it's just like Marmont
right it's just big taking into the
future so it's so inspirational to see
the the depiction of an African nation
that is self-determining that wasn't
interrupted by the assaults that is
colonialism and is able to figure out
how to realize its full potential that
the the the full potential of its
citizens you know where women can be
standing in their full power right by
men and not apologizing for them for
that power and the men are not
diminished by the realizing of that few
female power right by their side that's
really cool the film has Lapita playing
the character
Nakia and is directed by ryan coogler
now his last two films Fruitvale station
and creed were highly praised and
already the critical buzz for black
panther is overwhelmingly positive it
was a very very collaborative process
and Ryan is the kind of guy he leads by
example and he leads but with deference
often times you know he's gonna get
people experts to come to the table and
then he's gonna listen to them so in a
sense it's actus he was looking at me as
a nakiya's expert and so you come to the
table and he's not just interested in
you learning your lines he wants you to
have a say in how your character gets
developed and so for sure I felt that
way about Nakia